The answer is it would mean that NP is a subset of BQP.
It wouldn't mean that RSA is secure.
In fact, we know because of Shor's algorithm,
if someone can build a sufficiently large quantum computer,
they would be able to break RSA.
But it would increase our confidence, because it would put factoring
in the class of problems that are believed to be hard to solve in polynomial time
as long as P is not equal to NP.
If it's also showing that P is not equal to NP,
then this would mean that there is not any polynomial time solution for factoring
with a classical computer.
That would greatly increase our confidence that RSA is secure.
To see why this is the case, we can think about how complexity classes as sets of problems.
That makes the green circle the class NP.
We have the class BQP, which is not known whether it's a subset of NP.
We have the problem factoring, and we know factoring is somewhere in this circle.
The reason we know factoring is NP is we have solutions
that solve it in non-deterministic polynomial time.
Even the brute force solution, if we could execute all those passed at once,
would solve it in polynomial time.
The other way to see that it's an NP is there's an easy way to check if the answer is correct.
That's just multiplication.
That's enough to know that factoring is definitely within the NP circle.
We also know that it's within BQP.
If it's known to be NP hard, that would mean it's as hard as the hardest problem in NP.
It's also known to be in BQP, so that would mean that we'd have to squish--
everything in the circle would now be inside BQP,
because there is no problem that would be harder than factoring in NP.
I hope those of you who haven't yet studied the theory of computation
will forgive the full excursion, but this is a really important point to understand
what the security of RSA relies on--these assumptions about problems being hard.